yeah ask your question babe I'm ready
for that there's no point going to meet
your mom and talk about her blessing
with an engagement if we can't come to
an agreement on this second wife thing
you know what I'm saying
she have the right to ask me a question
about anything she feels like it's not
okay for her and um it's my
responsibility to clear her up because
tomorrow is the day for us to go to
sokoto so we can get my family blessing
but if we can't agree on this second
wife then no hope
good
who picks her like does your family
choose a woman for you my family will be
in the position to do that maybe when
you have kids right like what is my role
would you be like upset if I don't want
to like have involvement with them if
you want to see them
you can see them if you don't want to
see them
I don't have to blame you but I feel
like there is no how
you love Mother without loving us on if
now I say I don't want to see Jamal you
know like he's not my son blah blah blah
will you be happy no good
I mean what you said was it was a really
good point for me and it made me see it
now you know what I mean like because I
would be upset if you didn't like Jamal
or you didn't want to be around Jamal
as long as we are going to be husband
and wife in future Kimberly cannot just
tell me that I love you and then I do
love your children
it's not going to be possible so we just
need to understand the reality of it
definitely I know that my second wife is
going to be from Malaysia oh yeah
because she's not going to be from
America no you don't know him right now
no you don't know no I told you no you
don't know no that was it no you don't
know
if I have an American lady who live in
America and she's a house by tribe and
she can conceive and give me a child I
don't think I should be deprived from
that I'm not gonna you're not gonna do
that because if you do it there's no
point in me going because that's like a
deal breaker for me
it's like if this whoever your second
wife is from America it's not happening
I told you this
I just feel like if the second wife is
from America it's like too close to home
for me there has to be boundaries
between me and the second wife when he
comes to the states that should be my
time with him and I'm not trying to be
controlling I'm not trying to but I have
a say-so in this too
foreign